there aren't many predators as majestic
as the tiger and there may be none as
difficult to find in the wild there are
only five kinds of tigers left on the
planet down from eight just a century
ago and tiger populations continue to
decline when Tigers in humans meet the
results are often deadly for one or the
other the National Geographic
photographer Nick Nichols has a special
reverence for the big cats and Nick
hopes that by showing the world the
power and majesty of these beasts he can
help build a political will to protect
them we really wanted to just find a way
to get into their world it's such a
secret world nick has settled on a novel
approach he plans to capture a tiger on
film by taking himself out of the
picture he will set up a series of
remote video and still cameras in
India's band of gar National Park his
first challenge is finding some Tigers
for that Nick and his assistant Roy top
are getting some help from the local
elephant population and from their guide
nan de Rana
and by the end of the first week there
are camera traps all over the park on
Tiger trails near water holes even in
some places you wouldn't expect so we're
going to set up a camera in this case
someone gets really hot he may come in
here to get out of the heat but the
camera will be here like six weeks and
if we get to two tigers will be happy
one he's coming down when an animal
crosses the infrared beam it triggers
the cameras Tigers can come at all hours
so they spend a lot of time making sure
the lighting will work 24 hours a day
trying to find a way of take pictures
Tigers on their terms you know actually
the Tigers are taking their own picture
that's what it gets down to
while he's waiting for the traps to work
Nick bills a blind in the hopes he'll
capture a tiger in action
but he doesn't get the shots he's
dreamed up he has better luck tracking a
mother Tiger from the back of an
elephant when I see her it just makes me
shake there's so much adrenaline I can't
keep my camera off of her she's so
beautiful with Nick nearby she brings
the kill to her growing Cubs it's an
exhilarating moment but what about the
hidden cameras a few weeks after setting
them up Roy goes to check the traps he's
on foot in Tiger country that can be
risky he does your loud pitch right
there but that is there's a deer in this
area called Cheadle and when did they
see a tiger that's what they clean out
so so we listen for alarm calls we know
there's a tiger in the area and it's
pretty close real close
unbeknownst to roid but caught on film
by the hidden cameras a tiger approaches
a nearby pool for an afternoon dip
Roy finds evidence the tiger is closed
some believable it's the last half
kilometer we've seen cry 15 to 20 scrape
markets of this Tiger Tiger here's the
men approach does it see Charlie and
runs off before they arrive Roy never
sees the tiger but believes one may have
been in the pool it had been recently
some monkey but this is a lot of water
so no no I would think he was just in
here not too long ago it's a lot of
water out here whoa bingo 55 triggers
Tyrell yeah honey it's good video baby I
did back at the tent the photographer's
savor their success come on please maybe
this whole go in oh my god yes come on
Oh drink oh man
this is too cool the Tigers caught by
Nick straps appear to ignore the cameras
flashes and clicking shutters
Nick hopes these unique images Tigers in
their natural state will convey the
beauty of these magnificent beasts and
help promote his call to protect them
and so you hope that the photographs
have to take might have something to do
with the continuation of wild tiger not
the continuation of tigress in the noise
the wild times these are rare images of
an even rarer creature a tiger and the
wise